Yes. Yes. Oh my god. Now you're getting it. Oh, they're getting
Let's go. Now they're getting it. The second somebody goes to
your language is a little bit too much. Your language your language
your Shut up. Shut up. Tell me what has happened. Tell me the
events. Tell me what Israel has done.
Tweeted numbers today. Oh, that tweet did do numbers. That's
true. Hold on. Why am I not on that tweet?
Yeah, that this is pretty cool that it's like dude, if you want
to keep like if you want to keep canceling all the anti-Zionists
and calling them like anti-Semitic and eventually if you keep
making if you keep reinforcing the idea that you have to hate
to be against Israel and then Israel keeps doing what it's doing
it convinces a bunch of bunch of people that hating is okay.
Like eventually that will become the thing you're teaching people,
right? Careful. Oh. Oh. Like I'm not saying you should hate I'm
saying
the people who want to cancel like anti-Zionists for not supporting
Israel like they they do increase anti-Semitism. Um anti-Zionism
is rising as a response to what Israel is doing. Yeah, it is.
Yeah, it is.
They changed the name of the article. I know they did. Which
is makes it even funnier cuz Ezra picked this name for the article
and then I guarantee you a bunch of people were hyper seething
at the New York Times.
And so they had to change they had to change the title of the
article which is super funny, okay. Let's read the article, guys.
The article that's set the world on fire the online the Twitter
the center-left Twittersphere on fire today, okay? After the
2024 elections, there was a panic among Democrats about the absence
of a liberal Joe Rogan. Could one be found? Could one be created?
It was an epic exercise in missing the point. You don't have
a liberal Joe Rogan because Rogan is not particularly political.
His audience cohered around conversations with comedians, MMA
fighters, bodybuilders, and psychonauts.
That's what made him politically influential. He could reach
millions of people who are not otherwise interested in politics.
The problem Democrats actually had, one of them anyway was that
they didn't like Rogan and criticized others for going on his
show. They tried repeatedly to cancel him for his comments about
trans people and his skepticism of COVID
To the extent that he is now a right-wing or a right-coded figure,
it's not because he started that way. Rogan's political views
are mixed. He backed Bernie Sanders in 2020. He supports universal
health care and abortion rights. He dislikes vaccine mandates
and likes border control. But it shouldn't have been a surprise
when after years of being attacked by the left, he endorsed Donald
Trump in 2024.
The simplest way to tell people which side they're on is to tell
them how much your side hates
>> I mean, this does happen. People People hate that or
sorry, people really like that Nazi comic. You know the one where
like people shave their head and they're like, well, I really
hate to do this and the guy becomes a Nazi cuz people are mad.
Right? I'll tell you like people like to make fun of that and
they're like, oh well, I guess they weren't principled anyway.
Once you attack somebody enough that will happen.
Uh like yeah, the negative polarization thing absolutely happens.
Totally happens. Is a real phenomenon. Is a real thing that happens,
okay? Anyway, that brings me to a more important than it might
look controversy that has burst out over the leftist streamer
Hasan [__] He had a breakout moment over the past
year as Democrats began obsessing over the absence of a liberal
Joe Rogan and [__] who mixes leftist politics and
broish and a broish aesthetic was proffered as a possible answer.
A category error because again, the whole point of Rogan's political
power is that his show mostly avoids
But pick But pick over Piker's years of streaming and you can
find offensive things he said. Among them, that America deserved
9/11. That his favorite flag is Hezbollah's. That a liberal Zionist
is akin to a liberal Nazi. Oh no. Streamer has said offensive
things isn't really a news story. But then Abdul El-Sayed, the
more DSA-ish candidate in the Democratic Senate primary in Michigan,
began rallying with [__] That led Third Way, a centrist
group that previously demanded that Democrats draw a line in
the sand and shun Hasan [__] and his fellow haters
to send a letter to El-Sayed demanding details about how closely
you align with his most abhorrent views. Do you disavow? Do you
disavow Hasan? Look at LonerBox. Wait, what do you mean look
at LonerBox? Oh, the negative polarization thing. Um
I don't know if that's negative polarization to be honest with
you.
I don't think that is. I Maybe like slightly.
But unfortunately like with LonerBox and I know you guys won't
like this
Hasan either aligned with or
echoed some like very obvious and and upsetting lies about LonerBox
in a in like a personal sense. And so I understand why he's not
a fan of Hasan. In terms of the Zionism in terms of him like
becoming more pro-Israel, I think that happened because he had
like that seems that feels more like audience capture. Like he
started, you know, doing content with Destiny around Destiny
and the audience liked him and the audience went and supported
him. And as did the H3 audience and that those people went and
and supported him. I think I think it's more when you get inundated
with that information cuz LonerBox does look into things, but
if he's inundated with like pro-Israel pro-Zionist information,
then I think that ends up happening over time. Problem is the
Zionism and reflexive anti-leftism. Uh the the left in terms
of his dislike of the left, that's definitely negative polarization.
Although I don't know like
Yeah, I don't know.
I probably have as much negative polarization there as he does
so I can't exactly throw the first stone. Okay. Just become aware
of the inundation. Well, it's it's difficult to Yeah, it's difficult
to know. Like it's very easy to especially for political streamers,
if everybody who links you stuff all has like a certain bias,
you'll you'll move in that direction because they're going to
link you the best sources. They're going to consistently have
an answer for most of the things you look into. Right? Especially
if you're not that far like leaning that far that way. So that
will happen over time. That is part of the reason I've moved
further away from like the Israel stuff over time is I have a
bunch of people who are like anti-Zionist who link me stuff,
who talk to me. And that's been a part of my move. Now, I think
that's mostly in my opinion, that's mostly based on me also checking
information and like trying to disagree with those people along
the way.
And moving like in a normal way, but I mean it might just been,
you know, audience capture in that way. You do not have negative
polarization like LonerBox does. Um
I don't know. I think LonerBox is in like an understandable place.
If you agree with the premise of like this negative polarization
thing, I think he's in a pretty understandable place in terms
of his politics.
Not shocking he ended up there. That's not you being anti-Zionist
because you hate Zionists.
Well, I mean, I think as a I'd starting to get to the point where
as a byproduct I'm starting to very much dislike Zionists, but
no, I was literally a
You know? Like it is starting to become like a byproduct, but
it wasn't like a a cause. Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. He was
irresponsible with letting negative polarization affect him so
much.
Hmm.
I don't know about that. I I guess I just don't watch LonerBox
enough to know for sure. Like I I can say I don't like his positions
right now. I can say I think with like I really didn't like
during the stream he the last stream he did with H3, I really
didn't like how that went, right? I really didn't like that.
I thought that was quite bad. Like
I think he was doing the same thing everybody else was doing
to sort of manufacture consent for the war in a lot of ways and
it felt very frustrating.
I It felt very frustrating. I don't know how else to say it.
Okay, so Third Way, a centrist group that previously demanded
that Democrats draw a line in the sand and shun Hasan [__]
and his fellow haters sent a letter to El-Sayed demanding That's
the the Senate candidate, right? Senate primary candidate in
Michigan.
Demanding details about how closely you align with his most abhorrent
views. Jonathan Greenblatt, the head of the Anti-Defamation League,
said [__] reflected the dangerous normalization of
anti-Semitism in our politics. Politico then asked a number of
possible 2028 Democratic hopefuls whether they would appear on
Piker's show. Governor Gavin Newsom and Rahm Emanuel said they
would. Representatives Ro Khanna and Alexandria Ocasio Ortec
Ocasio-Cortez already had. Senators Cory Booker, Ruben Gallego,
and Elissa Slotkin said they wouldn't. Haha. Booker. Booker.
Booker. I think
Rather, I think there's Why is this bolded? Rather a lot wrapped
up in this controversy. So let's take it piece by piece. Is [__]
a hater as Third Way alleges? In an interview with the writer
Aaron Reigenberg [__] addressed some of his worst
comments. I find some of his answers compelling and others less
so. The comparison of liberal Zionists to Nazis, for instance,
is repugnant and not so much improved by [__] clarifying
that he opposes ethno-states. What made the Nazis notable wasn't
their support for an ethno-state. Ethno-states are common.
What I This is
Why would you say this? This seems very goofy. What made the
Nazis notable wasn't their support for an ethno-state. Ethno-states
are common. What made the Nazis notable was their effort to exterminate
the people.
Yeah, what gave them the right to do The ideological belief that
they were pure of blood. They were the superior race that they
could exterminate the untermensch and that that was not wrong
to do. The thing that the the ethno-state and the extermination
are rooted in the same belief, right?
That's the problem. That's like what's going on there.
That's very weird to just go like, no no no no no no no. Like
guys, they just wanted an ethno-state. Ethno-states are everywhere.
It's like Well, no. The pursuing the ethno-state at the expense
of the minorities in your culture or sorry, in your nation obviously
bad. Anyway.
Is it the ethno-states are common? No, they're not. No, they're
They're They're not that common. I'm sorry, they're not.
What K what is the definition of ethno-states where people say
ethno-states are common? What ethno-state is committing like
purges of their minorities, ethnic cleansings, to remain an ethno-state?
Are there a lot of them?
Japan Japan's purging minorities. Where is Japan purging minorities?
Get the [__] out of here. Yeah, this is what I think
this is what I thought was happening was people were doing this
goofy conflation where like if you have an ethnic majority you're
an ethno-state.
It's like that's not the same thing. Don't pretend it's the same
thing. That conflation is an obfuscation, okay?
Not the same thing at all. Okay, so in Piker's assertion that
his opposition is all is to all reactionary ideology is hard
to square with his admiration for Hezbollah. Sure. But to focus
only I mean
I would say he's probably not necessarily supportive of everything
Hezbollah does. The admiration is pretty squarely based on one
thing.
But it's fine. But to focus on the on only those comments is
to miss much else that [__] has said and believes.
He has also said from pogroms to the Holocaust have always been
singled out by those as in power as a scapegoat for the instability
and economic volatility that the people in power caused. A resilient
nascent anti-Semitism is a constant
He's called anti-Semitism gross, immoral, and a hate crime. He's
promoted Jon Ossoff, a Democratic senator from Georgia who's
as a 2028 presidential possibility. In previous presidential
primaries [__] supported Bernie Sanders who is also
It is an unusual form of hatred that calls out anti-Semitism
and promotes Americans for the presidency.
Very curious, isn't it?
>> Just a totally just a totally disgusting anti-Semitism
where he just keeps supporting to run the country. Very crazy,
very gross.
Very gross.
Well, hold on. But like
this isn't dispositive that you're anti-Semitic, right?
But given put together it is it is kind of dispositive, okay?
It's kind of dispositive. When you put multiple things together
here, I do think it becomes very silly. You have to make a very
complex argument to paint him as anti-Semitic. Anyway. I have
deep disagreements with [__] but he isn't a hater.
He's an anti-Zionist. And here I think the real stakes of this
fight come into view. Okay, you guys are going to hate on Ezra
But that's that's he's hit the nail on the head, okay?
That is precisely what the fight is about, what it's always been
about, and everybody coping that it's not about that needs to
stop. They all need to stop. That's what it's been about the
whole time.
Very obviously, very clearly
You know you know you can tell the difference between somebody
who hates Hasan because of Israel and everyone else. All of the
people who hate Hasan because of Israel do the most absurd argumentation
that he's this like crazy
If somebody just doesn't like Hasan and it's not like based on
some, you know, them getting sort of brainwashed with a couple
different like a like three clips or something, right? Their
criticism is this guy seems a little hypocritical because he's
like this rich dude, he doesn't really support his groups, and
I think he's like larping as a commie. I don't think he's really
a commie at all. I think he's like larping as a commie. The the
weird mutation that happened where it went from champagne socialism
to actually he's a dangerous
revolutionary communist who is trying to destroy democracy in
America, right? It becomes all the all the more less believable,
okay? It is far less believable when you realize
that both of those critiques are very
sort of like centered for on and built around the same group
of people who have been critiquing Hasan for a very long time.
That they swapped over from oh, he's just a totally he's just
a totally fake like lazy champagne socialist to he's a dangerous
revolutionary communist. And they both come from the same place.
It's like oh.
And what changed? A clip from before they started criticizing
him.
Little strange, that's all. Little little weird. Little weird.
But anyway, here I think the real stakes of the fight come into
view. We're living through a rupture in both the meaning and
the reality of Israel. A Gallup poll from February found for
the first time that more Americans sympathize with the Palestinians
than the Israelis.
Among Democrats the gap was overwhelming with 65% who sympathized
with the Palestinians and 70% with the Israelis. The difference
as I have argued is largely generational. Older Americans still
view the Israelis more sympathetically, but among Americans ages
18 to 34 53% side with the Palestinians and 23% with the Israelis.
This is new. Before 2023 young people and Democrats were more
likely to side with the Israelis. The China thing is concerning,
too. And again, you would if people focus on the China thing
you could actually and not like he's getting state sponsored
trips from China. Just that he's genuinely sympathetic to
That could be concerning if he were running for office.
But I don't I don't think he's running for office. He was essentially
calling Hasan anti-Semitic today, by the way, after he's after
stating he hates that attack. Curious.
Very curious.
An age divide. This is not a result This is not the result of
an international psyop or a profusion of all of memes. The Israel
that young people know is not the Israel that older people remember.
It responded to the savagery of October 7th by flattening Gaza
in a brutal campaign that killed at least 70,000 Gazans, taking
control of then half
control of more than half of the territory and hurting Gazans,
more than 2 million people, into the remainder. Life there remains
hellish. Israel's made hopes
for a two-state solution fanciful by slicing the West Bank up
into Israeli settlements and abetting constant settler violence
and keeping a boot on the throat of the Palestinian Authority.
It has used the Iran wars an opportunity to launch an invasion
of Lebanon, displacing more than a million people, and announcing
that as many as 600,000
won't be allowed to return to their homes until Israel decides
otherwise.
Oh, this is the Well, hold on. This is the Israel to destroy
all houses near Lebanon border, defense minister says. Dude,
how did this not get more outrage, man? How did this not get
It's just It's March 31st, dude. It's crazy. I don't I don't
know how that doesn't get more outrage, but all right. The Knesset
just voted to legalize hanging as a punishment for Palestinians
who are convicted of killing Israelis in terrorist attacks. They
always suggest you can identify haters by their use of loaded
words taught in social justice seminars, apartheid, genocide,
settler
It's so funny that it
again, anytime if you are talking about words, if you are talking
about language, the second somebody goes to your language is
a little bit too much. Your language your language your Shut
up. Shut up. Tell me what has happened. Tell me the events. Tell
me what Israel has done.
Explain to me what Israel has done. Do not talk about language
until you can actually go through and tell me the things Israel
has done in the past 2
Sorry, 3 years. We're going on nearly 2 and 1/2 years at this
point, okay? If you cannot list all of the crimes they've done,
you cannot list all the reprehensible [__] they've
done, then I don't believe you. I think what you're doing is
you're trying to pull the language back because you don't actually
like want to have this conversation. You don't want to go through
the crimes. You want to support Israel and you get really uncomfortable
when people start talking about the things they do. It's all
like a language game and I just don't want to play the language
game ever. It's very silly. My favorite part of this interview
was when Crystal was like, "Oh, so you support defensive aid
to Israel. Why wouldn't you also support defensive aid from Iran
or for Iran and Russia?" Then a stunned Slotkin had to pause
and explain the basic concept of allies and versus adversaries.
What a great genocidal ally we have. I never said Israel's a
great ally. I said they are an ally. It is a neutral correct
statement.
I mean, if they're a genocidal ally, I would say probably any
aid is bad. Any aid is bad. Yeah? Okay. Genocide can also become
a beautiful symbol for the first world world to to Jesus, man.
Jesus. This is why there's no outrage.
Like trying to back off. Everybody's trying to back off the Israel
position and it's very funny to watch. Hutch was starting to
back off the Israel position a little bit months ago. Not like
just not a fuse of support, okay?
So I I think there's probably decent chance that he's not really
been like very very pro-Israel in the past like 6 months or so.
We'll see. Oh, I saw this is disgusting.
There's reports that Apple Maps have removed village names from
Southern Lebanon while Israel while Israeli towns on the other
side of the border remain clearly labeled. Users are comparing
screenshots noting Google Maps still shows the same villages
while Apple shows terrain with no labels.
We've just looked into the matter and these reports seem false.
The villages never had names in the first place, which is why
people don't use Apple Maps in Southern Lebanon.
don't know why that would be. Why do
Why do they not have names in Southern
That that seems kind of weird from the very beginning. No? That
does seem very odd just at a base level.
So I saw this story that um that they'd removed the names and
that seemed bad. And it's like the Well, the names were never
there. It's like why?
Like I'm sorry, the reason the Southern Lebanon cleansing is
so bad is because Hezbollah is at its weakest the weakest they've
been in years and years and years with how beat up and battered
Iran is. And now is when you do the ethnic cleansing in Southern
Lebanon. Right? Like you have the US security guarantee still,
but now you're doing
Cool cool. And then I'm going to pull this tweet over as well.
This this pretty crazy.
More than 37,000 housing units have been destroyed or damaged
in Israeli attacks on Lebanon since March since March 2nd, according
to Lebanon's CNRS L. That's more than 16% of the 230,000 housing
units destroyed or damaged in Lebanon since October 2023.
So the the funny thing is is they literally just said they're
going to destroy all the housing units. They're just going to
destroy all the houses.
Like it's actual terrorism at that point. It's crazy. Japan doesn't
count as an ethno-state when they don't have um Sorry. Like here's
the thing. If you Ethno-states are bad, but if you're maintaining
your ethno-state via just purely like migration, like you're
just not allowing immigration, that's whatever. I don't really
care. You just don't want people from outside the country, whatever.
But doing it by actually cleansing people, by actually kicking
people out, that's different. It's bad.
Define ethno-state. I would say
people who are going to take actions against their own citizens
in order to uphold or not even citizens, their own
like I guess people who live in that country, live in those areas.
All right. All right. We keep going. We're not even done with
the article yet, guys. We're not even done.
Right. So Third Way suggests the way you can identify two haters
by the is by their use of loaded words taught in social justice
seminars, apartheid, genocide, settler colonialism.
If that is the test, then a large number of Americans now fail
it. Israel, as it is behaving today and as it is constructing
itself for tomorrow, is incompatible incompatible with any normal
understanding of liberal values.
Yes. Yes. Oh my god. Now you're getting it.
Now they're getting Let's go. Now they're getting it.
There will be no Palestinian state to the west of the Jordan
River. Benjamin Netanyahu said, "For years I've prevented the
creation of that terrorist state against tremendous pressure
both domestic and from abroad. We've done this with determination
and with astute statements statesmanship.
Moreover, we've doubled the settlement in Judea and Samaria,
and we will continue on this path." Anti-Zionism is rising as
a response to what Israel is doing.
It will simply not be possible to treat it as a marginal viewpoint
that can be shamed or shunned into invisibility. Yes, anti-Semitism
often cloaks itself in anti-Zionism. So don't do the anti-Semite
work for them. If you keep telling people that if they oppose
the state, then they must hate the people, eventually they will
believe you. So if you I I thought this point was really good,
right? Like stop stop tying the the two together. Stop making
it so opposing Israel, even even like vehemently or um
like hyperbolically
support Sorry. Hyperbolically opposing the state of Israel. Not
even that should be considered anti-Semitism.
Right? I think there's reason to be hyperbolic, to be ahead of
the curve. Uh like how much more evidence do you need that for
the past two and a half years, since October 7th, every hyperbolic
statement people have made about Israel,
you know, if it's if it's lagging their actions by 6 months,
you have not called them out as evil enough yet. Like unfortunately,
if you were like, "Oh, they're going to do evil sh
Not even the most vehement anti-Zionist realized how bad it was
going to get over the next 2 and 1/2 years. Right? I I I think
that's the problem is you can criticize the people who are being
hyperbolically anti-Zionist, but now you have to admit that yeah,
you were wrong. You were wrong, and they have taken advantage
of the situation, they have done a bunch of really heinous sh
Okay.
The impulse to cut off those with whom we disagree reaches far
beyond [__] or the Israel-Palestine Palestinian debate.
It sits at the heart of cancellation as a political tactic.
It relies on a belief in the power of gatekeepers that might
have been true in an earlier age, but no longer reflects the
way attention is earned and held. Tucker Carlson was ejected
from Fox News and grew stronger on X and YouTube. Nick Fuentes
was banned from major social media platforms and gathered strength
in the shadows. Trump went from being banned by every major social
media platform to retaking the presidency.
This I'm sorry, the deplatforming worked on Nick Fuentes. He
wasn't gathering strength in the shadows. He was like withering
away slowly.
Like he was legitimately having existential like crash outs once
every 6 months or something. Like I don't know how he could keep
doing this. You have me kicked off of everything. It's crazy.
Like it was working on Fuentes. People just stopped doing it,
and they He was He was honing his craft. He wasn't really gathering
strength in numbers. He was honing his craft. He was becoming
a better broadcaster, right? The whole time by doing his broadcast
all of the time. But it absolutely worked. The deplatforming
worked. The deplatforming worked, and deplatforming does work.
I just don't think you can't you can't deplatform somebody from
a political movement. Right? Like the idea of ignoring Hassan
doesn't work. All the other examples,
the Tucker Carlson ejected from Fox News, this is a way better
example, actually. Tucker Carlson is the analog, not Nick Fuentes,
not even Trump. But Tucker Carlson, it's like if you kick him
out of a party, but he's got a massive audience,
like you haven't done anything effective. Yeah, exactly. Exactly,
Porter Beller. And Fuentes had never built that up over time
cuz he got banned so early.
But it's not just that cancellation has failed to silence those
it targeted. It also weakened those who used it, the Democratic
Party and the progressive movement. was ill-served by the belief
that it could decide the boundaries of acceptable debate. In
narrowing who it could talk to, it limited what it could hear
and whom it could be heard by. I've been on Rogan's show, but
I've been on some of the shows in that broader universe, like
Andrew Schulz's Flagrant and Lex Fridman's podcast. I was surprised
by how frustrated those hosts were about their inability to book
Democrats in 2024.
They'd said things like the broader the They'd said things that
the broader progressive universe disliked or had conversations
with people who were anathema to the left. And and so Democrats
largely avoided these podcasts, seating them to the Trump campaign.
This was not only bad politics, but also bad democratic practice.
Those shows had come from nowhere and gained millions of loyal
listeners. They'd earned their viewerships by voicing something
that made millions of Americans feel seen feel seen, heard, or
at least interested. In avoiding those spaces, Democrats avoided
contact with those kinds of voters with the kinds of voters,
sorry, that they claim otherwise claim to represent. This is
the mistake Democrats often make when they talk about what they
did wrong in 2024. They realize now that they should try to talk
to the people who listen to these shows. They are less likely
to realize that they should listen to the people who talk on
these shows. Ooh. Ooh.
Oh sh I think this is like the lesson you should have learned
from Trump, right?
To be honest with you,
this is the lesson you should have learned from Trump. Hey, um
you should understand why Trump's message resonates. If you can't
understand why Trump's message resonates,
if you can't listen to the people who who Trumpers like and and
Trump himself and understand and get it, then you are You are
totally
It's why you keep going, "Hey, what the heck? This guy just threatened
to genocide people. Where Why is he still approved of? Why Why
do people still approve of this guy?" Although I will say at
this point at this point the Trump thing has jumped the shark
entirely and is entirely cult-based and is entirely like like
at this point you need American de-Ba'athification or something.
Like at this point America You have to America's mind, okay?
Unironically,
Z was right on that one thing, okay? It's like holy sh
Things are insane.
Like at this point when he's saying,
if if it does break in the direction of he threatens to kill
he threatens to like genocide an entire civilization,
and all of the people who say that's disgusting are now anathema
to the entire right wing of US politics, Tucker Carlson, Candace
Owens, Dick Fuentes. If they do actually fall off, and there's
some sort of MAGA movement that that somehow like limps on for
the next 2
I don't know what to say. It's like
That That's beyond anything I could have conceived of. But that's
not how Trump built the cult in the first place, okay? You do
have to go back and listen and understand how he built the cult
in the first place. And yes, you even have to say, "Okay, I understand
why Bernie Sanders was popular at that same time, why he was
like a similar kind of movement, why he had success, and the
the mirrored attributes of the two of them, okay?" It's It's
like, dude, I swear to god, people are like, "My life feels like
it's getting worse." And they're like, "I don't How many charts
do I have to" This is the Democratic response. "No, I got a bunch
of charts that show you your life's way better than it ever has
been before." And now we're on like year 10 to year 12 of people's
lives getting worse, and they're like, "No, I found a new chart
that still explains how your life's actually getting better."
It's like, "Okay, there's a limit. There's a limit to how far
you can do or how far you can go with this." And yes, people
will start choosing like something that doesn't match reality,
right? If you keep telling people that America's doing better
than ever, we're rich we're richer than ever, things are going
good, which isn't broadly happening anymore, but it was for a
long time, okay? And it's not, and people are their lives are
getting worse. Oh boy. Oh boy.
I can't I can't explain to you how bad that's going to go over
time.
It could go bad. But beneath this is an important principle.
Conversation is not a reward to be bestowed on those with whom
we agree. It's a necessary habit in democracy. The point is not
to find agreement so much as to deepen understanding. To talk
with others is to believe in the possibility of change, theirs
and your own. Whether you like everything that someone has said
should should be severed from the question of whether that person
is worth talking to. So I think this is true.
oh man, how do I put it? This is like kind of true. No, I would
say it's true, but like if you're going into a space where people
disagree with you, you have to understand how those people think
because you should be able to adapt your your worldview. I'm
not saying you lie, you just code-switch. You say the same things,
but you try to say them in the ways that make sense for those
people, right? Highlight things that are good. If if there is
a significant pressure to go on these shows and do nothing but
push back and like aggressively attack, I do think that
that actually
I think fails in the long term. Like I think broadly that reinforces
this idea that Democrats are like these snooty people who can't
have a conversation and will constantly chastise you. No, I said
code-switch, don't lie. You don't hide your power level. Right?
You don't hide your power level. You speak in a way that speaks
to them.
And the the best influencers will be be the people who can do
that. That's how it is. That's how it's always been.
Uh not to say you don't say where you're principally disagreeing,
right? But you should understand where your disagreements are
if you're going on to a big platform, let's say, to talk to
you should understand where your disagreements are and you should
understand how to voice those without sounding like you're chastising.
Okay. The space for such conversations was once wider. In 1968,
William F. Buckley Jr., the arch the arch conservative founder
of National Review,
hosted Eldridge Cleaver, the Minister of Information for the
Black Panthers, on Firing Line. Neither man was there to endorse
the other's politics. I should like to begin by asking Mr. Cleaver
whether he finds it consistent with his ideology to encourage
the assassination of Richard Nixon. Buckley said, Cleaver's answer,
"I would say that if Richard Nixon was assassinated, it would
only result in having another pig in line who possibly would
need to be
That's awesome. Let's go.
>> That's cool. Dude, bro, don't this guy this is deeper
systemic issue. That's like that's like saying should we have
a very very like long and contemplative conversation about hitting
a mosquito that just bit you. Like bro, no. Even if you hit that
mosquito, this is not going to make a difference, okay? There's
a bunch of mosquitoes. Anyway,
Buckley later hosted Cleaver at his home. It was a different
time, but it created a lasting artifact. The interview has hundreds
of thousands of views on YouTube and remains riveting to
Are there people I won't have on my show or shows I won't go
on? Sure, but those are judgments for me and more about what
I think will be productive rather than who I think can be included.
Similarly, I wouldn't judge Booker, Gallego, or Slotkin for avoiding
Piker's show. They're busy people and it may not be how they
want to spend their time. But there's something strange about
aspiring to lead the country's left-wing coalition and elevating
the avoidance of prominent leftists to a matter of
That's all the more true now, as attention isn't bestowed on
the chosen few by television networks and newspaper editors.
It's won or lost in a ferocious marketplace that rewards outrage
and
The winners of the attention wars today are typically people
who said some outrageous things in the past or or are still saying
them in the present. When you're dealing with podcasters or streamers
who talk unstructured, unrehearsed for hours each week, if not
every day, there's going to be so much said that it's almost
inevitable that a dossier of dumb statements can be compiled.
To write those people out of acceptable polit- political discourse
is to back yourself into a shrinking sanitized corner of the
public sphere. Yes.
You do a I don't even I can't do an a Buckley accent, no. But
this is um this is what we've been railing on for like a long
time now. I've I feel like I've said this precisely multiple
times that like, "Hey, I understand there's like a reason that
Hasan's audience will like push back and be so upset by these
characterizations and it's cuz they have to listen to this sit
there and be like boring and just talk about democracy and how
to like achieve electoral victories and all day. That's what
they do all day. So they're like they then have to hear about
how he's like a dangerous radical who wants to destroy democracy
and they're like,
that's like incompatible with the vast majority of his content.
So I just don't get it. It's basically this is a rebuke of of
clipping culture as it's used in like the political sphere, right?
Like hey, if you just
one, Trump, but two, also like these streamers talk all the time.
They're it's literally a flow like a a stream of consciousness
all the time. Of course dumb things are said all the time. Of
course, of course, of course.
Booker admitted on Pod Save America
that when he had when he when he said he would never go on Piker's
show, he had not even heard of [__] His communications
director had read him a list of the four or five worst things
[__] had said and Booker used that as a basis for
his response. Booker got piled on for that admission, but I appreciated
the honesty. That is in practice a version of how many of us
make our
Oh, sorry. A version of how many of us make our judgments. Wrong
inflection.
Algorithmic media is an engine of motivated decontextualization.
Yeah? Yeah? You think so?
For sure. It I mean it is. It obviously
We see other people in snippets that serve the agendas of those
who cut them.
>> Yes. Clippers Clippers rule the world? He's saying Clippers
rule the world right now. Let's go.
Let's go. We are fed 30-second clips shorn from multi-hour streams,
two-sentence quotes ripped from long conversations, old comments
that obscure subsequent change. We have to be careful about being
lulled into believing these shards represent anyone's whole person.
We should not be afraid of finding out who those people
of seeking to change them, or allowing ourselves to be changed
by them.
Oh my god. It's so good. It's so I didn't think Ezra Klein could
spit like
It's actually so good.
Right? It's so good. It's Yeah, exactly.
Now, the clips can still be used and and they'll change people's
minds, but realistically, if you are an if you're somebody who
analyzes politics, analyzes political figures, and you are being
fooled by this stuff, you are like you
you're like a cow who owns a ranch, okay? You are cattle yourself.
You're cow who owns a ranch. You are you're going to be replaced.
Don't worry, you're going to be replaced. You'll we'll we'll
find you. We'll we'll figure out where you are and we'll get
you back out in the fields chewing grass very soon, okay?
You'll be back out there. Just don't be like I totally get it.
I get how, you know, random people who are just going about their
day on Twitter, they don't have time to look into all this stuff.
They will go, they'll see these clips, but the people who are
consistently only using these clips to make points,
yeah, I disagree. Disagree that, you know, in a political sense.
If you have one comment from a stream like 5 years ago about
Hasan possibly hiding his power level, maybe,
that I don't think really even says that, by the way. If that's
your if that's your your go-to, okay?
Get the [__] out of here with the dangerous like
radical who's going to destroy democracy [__] Makes
no sense.
Makes no sense at all. Yeah, great article. I thought I think
this reads like Ezra Klein is David Attenborough analyzing us.
yeah, honestly, the shocking thing about this is I feel like
I feel totally vindicated. I feel like everything said in this
article is precisely what I was telling people. Like like shockingly
bar for bar like shockingly
on the money with exactly what I've been saying for like at least
3 months, maybe 6 months now. Uh even longer when we go back
and we tie this into like the Hasan is bad stuff and how people
are using those clips to justify a bunch of garbage.